with a story that runs across five hours
of television in December 2019 in
January 2020 crisis on Infinite Earths
is set to include not just all of the
current DC shows but also a roster of
Heroes drawn from a long history of
television it's exciting stuff but it
raises a question just how did we get
here
the CW's version of crisis on Infinite
Earths is notable for being the first
event of its kind to take place on
television but the comic book history
that leads up to it starts all the way
back in 1961 or depending on how you
look at it maybe even before then back
in the 40s after Superman was introduced
to the public and proved to be wildly
popular and extremely profitable for its
publishers he inspired a whole wave of
brand-new superhero comics eventually
the company that would become DC Comics
decided to put a few of them in the same
book creating the Justice Society of
America and the first shared universe in
comics by the late 40s and early 50s
however superheroes fell out of
popularity only the most consistently
successful hero stuck around while the
rest like the original Golden Age
versions of the flash and Green Lantern
were canceled and seemingly condemned to
obscurity but then a decade later DC
decided to dust off a few of those pulpy
concepts and reboot them in a slightly
more sci-fi direction kicking off the
Silver Age of comics with an all-new
mostly different version of the flash
right from the start though there was
something weird Barry Allen was inspired
to take the name the flash because he'd
read comics about Jay Garrick the Golden
Age flash with that DC began to flirt
with the idea of a multiverse where
different versions of their characters
existed in different realities this all
came together in 1960 once famous the
flash of two worlds where Barry and Jay
met up for a single adventure it turned
out that this was just the beginning by
1964 DC had a multiverse centered on
earth 1 the somewhat arrogantly named
primary DC universe that featured the
ongoing Adventures of the present-day
heroes
meanwhile the Golden Age versions
politely allowed themselves to be called
earth 2 despite the fact that they came
first clearly there was only one thing
left to do a crossover Justice League of
America number 21 and 22 featured crisis
on earth
and crisis on earth-2 in which the
Justice League teamed up with their
golden age counterparts in the Justice
Society to battle for the fate of two
universes this kicked off two important
DC traditions first with the idea of an
annual Jael a JSA crossover which
continued for the next 20 years the
second was that almost all of these
crossovers which spread out through the
DC Multiverse were called a crisis
making that the shorthand word for a
threat that went beyond the scale of a
single universe eventually though things
spiraled to the point of being as big as
they possibly could in 1985 DC made a
very bold promise for their new series
worlds will live
worlds will die and the universe will
never be the same for the most part they
delivered with a year-long event called
crisis on Infinite Earths the company
was restructuring their entire
multiverse into a single streamlined
whole but rather than just rebooting all
the comics they made it part of a story
a villain called the anti-monitor who
presumably did not monitor things was
wiping out universes and the ones that
remained coalesced into a single unified
timeline in the process major characters
like the flash and Supergirl were killed
off with as much permanence as there can
be in superhero comics which is to say
they were dead for about 20 years before
they inevitably came back that wasn't
quite the end though the crisis brand
was so strong that DC kept it around
even after they bailed on the multiverse
another event devoted to fixing up the
complicated DC u timeline was called
zero hour crisis and time and there was
a modern-day JLA JSA team up against the
fifth dimension called crisis times five
in 2006 Infinite Crisis as its name
implies came along to perverse all the
changes and reintroduce the multiverse
the branding loomed large in the minds
of fans as the biggest world shattering
events in DC's long history one of the
things that makes the TV version of
crisis on Infinite Earths so interesting
is that it's following in the same
tradition as its comic-book counterparts
once arrows surprising success led to a
series of spin-offs and other shows
debuted in their own universes trying to
cash in on the massive popularity of
superheroes these days
seeing them team-up became inevitable
much like it had in the comics the idea
of an annual crossover quickly became a
tradition for the air overs it started
with Ollie Queens teaming up with a
flash for a couple of story arcs that
ran through the respective shows in 2014
and then a backdoor pilot for legends of
tomorrow the following year things
really started to pick up in 2016 that
March saw the Super Girl episode world's
finest which saw the flash vibrating his
way to super girls universe now called
earth 38 that then led to a full-on
three-part arrowverse super girl
crossover called invasion and then just
to cap things off March 2017 saw duet an
episode of flash where Supergirl showed
up for a singing dancing team-up that
took advantage of the Stars musical
theatre backgrounds with a few catchy
tunes I was singing for you know I name
anymore I mean it's worth noting that
both world's finest and Invasion were
both named after crossover comics the
long-running Superman Batman team-up
title and a 1988 event in which three
alien races invaded earth at the same
time respectively that tradition was
continued with crisis on Earth X which
like the comic it was named for featured
the introduction of a world ruled by
Nazis complete with an evil Supergirl it
turned out that earth axe was a secret
53rd earth that nobody ever talked about
because they all agreed it was terrible
in December of 2018 the arrowverse
launched Elseworlds a crossover that ran
through Green Arrow flash and Supergirl
and to call it ambitious is under sewing
things quite a bit for one thing it
involved twisting the set up of the
previous crossovers by also throwing in
a body swap between the flash and arrow
which gave us a truly delightful moment
of Grant Gustin growling Oliver Queen's
catchphrase at a robot
[Music]
more importantly Elseworlds served as
the arrow versus introduction to
Batwoman in the comics the modern bat
woman Kate Kane had been introduced in
2006 before taking over Detective Comics
for a year as a lesbian she was DC's
most high-profile queer character with a
backstory that saw her being dismissed
from the Army while at West Point under
the Don't Ask Don't Tell policy
she's also Bruce Wayne's cousin and on
the show Batman's absence from Gotham
City has inspired her to take on a
heroic identity of her own her
appearance in the Elseworlds crossover
where she was portrayed by Ruby Rose
paved the way for bat woman to join The
CW's lineup the thing is Elseworlds was
not the self-contained crossover that
crisis on Earth X was this specific body
swap story was wrapped up but the
crossover also spent a lot of time with
the monitor the anti-monitor and the
psycho pirates all of whom were key
characters in the comic book version of
crisis on Infinite Earths setting up the
next big crossover a year in advance
they even have the other major character
introduced in the original crisis
Harbinger who was actually brought to TV
way back in arrows first season as Lyla
Michaels head of Argus and wife of John
Diggle right now the CW shows have a
huge amount of characters and parallel
worlds to play with when they're setting
up a gigantic multiversal crossover
there's the arrow verse of course
anchored by green arrow and the flash
with heroes like vibe mr. terrific
Black Canary killer frost and even more
obscure characters like gun-toting
weirdo Wild Dogs showing up in their
supporting casts there's also legends of
tomorrow with firestorm with the atom
white canary vixen and more Plus
Stapledon and John Constantine bringing
actor Matt Ryan back for the role after
the cancellation of Constantine and
brought in Western hero Jonah Hex in an
episode where a 12-foot tall Care Bear
fought a demon and of course we have
that woman outside of that specific
universe though the CW also has
Supergirl and the heroes of Earth 38
including cara danvers Jon Jones the
Martian Manhunter The Guardian the
masked heroic identity of Superman's pal
Jimmy Olsen the Legion of super-heroes a
team from the 31st century with a
sprawling roster all its own and you
know Superman and the network also airs
Black Lightning which features the title
care
along with his daughters Jennifer and
Anissa the heroines known as thunder and
lightning and grace Choi who was a
member of The Outsiders alongside
Thunder in the comics but wait there's
more those are just the shows going on
now before the current run of successful
shows the CW and its predecessors also
ran Smallville which started as a teen
drama focused on a younger Clark Kent
but ran for 10 years and wound up
including everyone from Hawkman to
Zatanna
in 2002 there was the short-lived birds
of prey another take on a female focused
Batman free Gotham City about Batman and
Catwoman daughter the Huntress Plus
Oracle and black Canary those are all in
play for TVs crisis on Infinite Earths
and that's just the heroes the stage is
set for crisis on Infinite Earths to hit
the airwaves in December and from
everything we know so far it's going to
be big one where the Nazis won World War
two when where Kennedy was never
assassinated one more where all of us
are evil been there it sucks we already
know that characters from Smallville are
going to be showing up with Tom Welling
and Erica Durance for pricing their
roles as that universe as Clark Kent and
Lois Lane perhaps surprisingly birds of
prey is back in the mix too with Ashley
Scott stepping back in the role of
Helena Kyle the Huntress 17 years after
birds of prey was canceled there is even
more stunt casting to Kevin Conroy who
has been the voice of Batman in various
video games and animated projects since
he took on the career-defining role for
Batman the Animated Series in 1992
will be playing a live-action Bruce
Wayne for the first time the details
have yet to be released by the CW but he
definitely looks like he'll be playing
the older version of Bruce that he
voiced on Batman Beyond even more
intriguing Burt Ward who played Robin on
the 1966 Batman television show
alongside the late Adam West has also
been cast in an unannounced role also if
Tyler hoechlin and Tom Welling weren't
enough Superman for you crisis on
Infinite Earths also marks Brandon
Roth's return to playing the Man of
Steel the weird thing here is that while
he starred in 2006 his Superman Returns
wrath already has a role in the
arrowverse as Ray Palmer that are known
as the atom seeing him get another shot
as an older Superman with a costume
inspired by Mark Waid and Alex Ross's
kingdom comes
reline is intriguing it's not just that
Roth will presumably be pulling
double-duty but because whatever the big
problem is in crisis it's going to need
at least three super men to solve it
even more than the destruction of the DC
Multiverse the crisis on Infinite Earths
comic book is remembered for featuring
the deaths of Supergirl in the flash
that might seem pretty ominous
considering that the TV version is going
to prominently feature both of those
characters but in reality they're
probably the two major characters who
have the least to worry about they are
after all the stars of their respective
shows which from all indications are
both going strong into the indefinite
future with the CW announcing that
arrows 8th season will be its last
Oliver Queen on the other hand might not
be so safe even there though it seems
unlikely there are still two more
episodes of arrow scheduled to air after
crisis on Infinite Earths ends and while
one wrap up episode about always pals
dealing with his death would be
understandable two would be pushing it
that doesn't mean they won't pull it off
though stranger things have happened
once you've done an interdimensional
team-up musical nothing's out of the
question
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite DC storylines are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one